[Music]
i had a lot of jobs odd jobs as a
teenager
and as a tween
but one of the jobs i had as a teenager
was as an ice cream shop
boy at carvel
i always really loved carvel and now i
had like free access to
its product and i would
really take advantage of it i would eat
dinner there i had like several helpings
of ice cream i would make my own
concoctions like
mixing up the almonds with you know the
stuff that hardened the uh
the dipping stuff that hardened i
wouldn't
pour that into the dip yeah i forget i
guess we called it and you never felt
bad for not paying for any of it uh no i
never did i didn't look like sociopaths
no i didn't eat that much you're
sweating
they're fine but i did get my
comeuppance because i developed
lactose intolerance because i hate so
much of it and so i guess i did pay for
it in the end and i guess i'm paying for
it now too because your lactose
intolerance has a direct impact on yeah
my nose because we're often around each
other and
for our lactose intolerant listeners so
thanks carvel justin farts
barn when i have
dairy anyway here's the show enjoy
speaking of farts
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life with shorts i'm
your party host justin long life could
be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my fartless yes
occasionally farty of course that was a
good hookup though that carvel
i didn't take advantage of it because
those two it was before i could drive so
i really had no way of getting there i
think i saw either 13 once or twice
i dated a girl who worked at
baskin-robbins when i was a tween and i
took
full advantage of that hookup i i
i got a lot of free high school yeah
yeah i know but it
i don't know why this all seems like
sexual to me now what and she would just
hook you up with different yeah it was
it was also back in the day where you
could have ice cream or anything
completely guilt-free yeah
god i wish i it didn't even i remember i
mean now obviously
not not obviously but now
whenever i have any sort of sweet
there's at least a moment usually more
than one moment where i think this is
not healthy doesn't that sucks but back
then
i never crossed my mind never i mean it
did if i ate too much and i like my
stomach hurt or something i'd be like oh
i guess that wasn't good for me yeah i
made it i never thought about the
calories or anything no it was just the
immediate like yeah you're right if you
made yourself nauseous and i'm not
exaggerating by how much ice cream i
would eat
i had like uh that's all i ate i would
we would have like you know an
eight-hour [ __ ] disgusting and those
were the days oh god so fun well why are
we talking about
excessively eating ice cream because our
guest today
used to excessively eat ice cream until
he quit it's one of his favorite things
it's uh he talks about it today you'll
hear him
wax poetic about how much he loves ice
cream and by the way there's no better
ice cream than carvel please be a
sponsor they're the best they are really
good i don't know if they're the best oh
really you know i've had i've had better
ice cream yeah maybe but like as far as
like popular chains go yes yes for sure
creamy and delicious
anyway speaking of creamy and delicious
please don't look at me when you say
that next time
creamy delicious
i'm conflating uh
pleasurable
taste now with sexual appetite anyway uh
speaking of doing that our guest today
is jeff garland you know him maybe not
necessarily as an ice cream lover though
you're about to uh you probably mostly
know him from
my favorite show curb your enthusiasm
and my favorite show the goldbergs
i'm just kidding
no he's on the goldbergs i'm not kidding
about that he does talk about that and
the difference between doing the
goldbergs and curb which to us is
it's a pretty uh large chasm yeah
they're very different shows
um very popular equally popular he is
ours
oh i bet it is yeah um he is our second
guest from curb enthusiasm that we've
had our first guest being jb smoove and
we are slowly chipping away at
eventually getting to larry david oh god
the uh what do you what do they call
that mecca the pride what's the prize on
the the gold
the uh holy grail the holy grail yeah
holy grail of podcast guess um
he is he's actually also our
third i think guest that's affiliated
with the goldbergs kevin smith and leah
thompson both have directed episodes
whoa
crazy
but we should
we should also mention that he has a
really
funny
uh really great stand-up special on
netflix called jeff garland our man in
chicago
and he was just such a i've known him
for a while i don't want to get into it
but uh why not well we're supposed to
get into it but
well i'm gonna get into it in the
interview oh right right don't we kind
of well maybe not maybe you met him
doing a movie called strange wilderness
just for some context that's where you
met him but you didn't
get to know him too well right am i
wrong
i'm wrong no you're right so i'm not but
you enjoyed his company and you enjoyed
working with him i really did but you
didn't develop much of a friendship no
uh because he only worked i think a day
on that he worked with oliver hudson and
um maybe he worked two days harry hamlin
anyway uh if
if you know the movie the movie's not
very well known but um strange
wilderness but it's it's a stoner comedy
from happy met adam sandler's company
happy madison and i loved doing that
movie so much uh we improvised most of
it and it was just this really fun dumb
stoner movie anyway that's where i met
jeff um i was a huge fan of his going in
so
uh and meeting him hanging out with him
did not disappoint so we we kind of
catch up about that a little bit but
you're right i didn't know him that well
he
you guys talk about a story in the
interview that he tells in his stand
special but
force just for some context we should
briefly
tell the story just so it makes sense
yeah that'll be true that's because we
allude to it in the interview and then
he doesn't want to tell it right because
he wants people to see the yeah the
special understandably yeah uh however
we're going to tell you really quickly
what it is so the story is he is um
driving his car in a parking lot and he
basically long story short he um this
person steals his parking spot
and and then
she goes on to make fun of him for being
overweight yeah she
she makes a gesture indicating that he's
overweight and he flies into a fit of
anger and he gets out of his car just to
talk to her just to because he's so
curious what type of person would do
such a thing so he goes over to her car
and knocks on her window and
i guess he knocks on his window too hard
and it shatters her window
and she panics and then she you know
thinks that he's attacking her and he
immediately backs up he's like no i'm
sorry i'm so sorry i'm so sorry and he
goes into the store he apologizes and
when he comes out the cops are there
she's called the cops so he gets
arrested so that is the story that
they're referring to and now jeff if
you're listening to this i'm so sorry
for telling it because i know you want
people to but for those listening listen
it's such a because he tells it in a
great way much more much better when
we're telling it we're just giving you
the bullet points but it's such a
watch this special it's great and that
story is at the center of it um and and
that story is the springboard for a lot
of things that happen in jeff's life
that we're also going to get into so
here we go getting into it right now uh
my my chat my convo
what's a good word to say uh not convo
right now
my uh conversation my conversation yeah
what one of my dads why am i trying to
be cute i don't know what chit chat
you're thinking back to your ice cream
days yeah maybe uh anyway here's jeff
garland
here's jeff garland
swing
life could be a dream
[Music]
you scared the hell out of me sorry
i'm a big hugger
and i adore you like [ __ ] oh no it felt
good actually not good all right i
haven't had a nice big like
man hug in a while that's me it's nice i
i haven't when's the last i i'll tell
you the last time i saw you i swear to
god i bumped into you
and your girlfriend at the movies in
century city
yeah the last time i saw you
yes yep and this is how
horrible my memory is or how many
failed relationships i've had i forget
who the girl was drew oh okay okay yeah
by the way
i'm divorced now and that's all life is
about is
piling up yeah like
carcasses
you think like i spent all this time i
mean right you must experience a tenfold
with a
you were married for someone 25 years
yeah
but i'm but i'm we have children
yeah and i aspire to keep my close with
her yeah i don't even talk about her in
my stand up oh that's good well we by
the way i should have prefaced by saying
anything we say here you cut out you can
tell i want to go comfortable i'm all
good rarely i mean every once in a while
i'm like oh i wish we hadn't discussed
that but then just tell me but it's not
it's usually not personal stuff it's
just me having an opinion on something
in the world that i really don't give a
[ __ ] about you you know because you talk
about that in the stand up a little bit
having said something definitely on the
goldberg yeah my vagina hurts yeah
and somebody complained to hr yeah isn't
that crazy yeah no no i mean it's just
so stupid and that was my attitude in hr
was like yeah yeah call
call anyone tell anyone fire me i'd love
to be fired with jeff crowley who got
fired for his vagina a great headline it
would be but it would also put the
the
i would expose the absurdity of where we
are because look i think me too has to
have happened and
i think for me as a man
common sense of being respectful
thoughtful and kind
i don't get in those areas yeah i like
trying to
unpack
why something was offensive like in this
case
why would somebody be offended by that
like you said in the stand up clearly i
don't have a vagina right it's obviously
like i don't know but sometimes
you know you don't
you don't know you don't know their
history i once offended someone who i
found out had a real tragic history
by um i forgot what it was it was
someone i knew very well and i i hugged
her
and then she was upset about it i didn't
know you heard you're too long
no god no i don't do that no it's a big
hug
but it was someone that i was friends
with
not someone i really thought and then
when we discussed it later
it was totally cool like she told me her
uncomfortable feelings and stuff it was
all clear isn't that great
i i just wish we could do that with
everyone on twitter i wish there was a
but it's not that twitter is a place for
people
who aren't funny and don't have a sense
of humor to express themselves
i'm not involved in twitter i don't read
that i've stopped you know i i closed my
account a couple years ago oh yeah and
twitter had helped me set it up i went
to twitter in san francisco oh wow i was
all in on the twitter
now i just do instagram because at least
you have to put a picture up and
i block anyone
who says something it's always funny the
people who say
the worst things which are rare on
instagram so i go to see what their page
is about they always private and guess
what
they either have no posts which is usual
yeah four posts like not many posts
and
not many followers yeah so it's all
about you know i don't understand well i
got into a thing over the about uh last
weekend with a woman if i was in fort
lauderdale at a film festival and i had
been they i got a little shanghaied into
this party which i think may be an
offensive term now to be shanghaied i
don't know but i stopped worrying about
it okay you didn't mean it you weren't
thinking of that i was i was
although i've never used i know that
term
well you know years ago on curb
i improvised indian gift that larry
you're indian given larry goes you know
that's a racist term yeah and i'm like i
guess it is isn't it but what is it
that's the guy who wrote that the
episode the cigar store indian yeah i
know but but the thing that's weird
about it is also when you think about it
i never knew growing up about indians
giving something of it no i didn't
either we did that to them but maybe
that's where the term comes maybe so it
should be pejorative for like white
colonial [ __ ] yeah white cologne
exactly so i i didn't quite realize but
go ahead well shanghai i know well
because i was when i was a kid we loved
laurel and hardy and there's a great
laurel and hardy short where they get
knocked on the head and they wake up on
a boat and they're you know indentured
surfer too uh but i was taking i was at
some function whatever they
they gave me an award but
you know they appeal to actors egos but
really want them to take pictures and
show up at things right yes that's
what's great right yeah so i was at one
of these things and i was feeling um i
made the mistake of smoking a little
weed so i was a little like paranoid we
did not think it was going to be like uh
this situation with the photos and stuff
so we had just finished taking all these
things photos and sat down we ordered i
was so excited to eat i was in a little
corner and a woman walked up and said
and i'm not i'm i'm mildly paraphrasing
but this is basically what she said
uh she said
hi i need you to um
i need you to to meet my people
get up and meet my people she kind of
gestured over the other side of the
restaurant crowded restaurant and i said
oh
and i'm not exaggerating i said oh wait
yeah she goes yeah come on come on it
won't take long they're over there and i
said what people should my friends my
people
they recognize you and they want to meet
you and i said oh you know what i'm
about to eat dinner is it okay if i do
it right after as soon as i'm done with
it she said
it'll only take a second
and i said oof and i'm so bad at drawing
boundaries i was really proud of myself
for saying oh you know i'm a people
pleaser i want people to like me and
normally i probably would have gotten up
and like gone through the crowd and and
there was something about the way she
was doing it was so rude and like and
she she said i really it'd only take a
second i said i'm sorry i'll do it as
soon as i'm done with dinner and she
rolled her eyes and she said
okay
and walked back to her friends and i got
so paranoid oh no she's upset and i
looked back and sure enough she was
talking about me i could see her
gesturing to me and i make a thing to
the friends i'm just gonna eat i'm just
gonna eat really quick and i'll be right
over
and i ended up at the end of the meal
not going out of my way i couldn't find
them but i also didn't go out of my way
to go see them and part of me was like
you know [ __ ] this lady
and the next morning on twitter i
checked to see if something i'd done the
night before was on there i was on some
local news show i wanted to send to
somebody and um
this woman had written to me and i i got
to read the word for word she said
she called me she misspelled it she
called me a douchebag but you'll
appreciate this i could read to exactly
what she wrote uh sorry this is going to
take a second she said
uh first she wrote me two hashtag justin
long private party tonight what a douche
bag
douchebag wore his pjs and could not be
bothered i wore a shirt because i didn't
have a button-down shirt then sent
another one hashtag [ __ ] ed norton
was an [ __ ] to my friend betty add
justin long to the list
what a jerk
work his war she meant his pajamas to a
high-class party and disrespected us all
his grandmother should hit him upside
his head what a friggin liar but
basically what she wrote tells everybody
what they need to know
yeah what as does i then looked on yelp
my friend found her yelp account and
she's written 158 yelp reviews and i
spent way too long
reading these reviews the detailed i was
they weren't friendly enough to me and
we waited 20 minutes and he's a mentally
ill person right yeah who's also a
narcissist obviously a huge nurse but
like
i and what i hate is that i had given
her so much time and i was she's oh by
the way
you need to be friends with me yeah i
mean we're friendly we're acquaintances
which is a real word real word was like
you know somebody yeah when you're an
acquaintance it's not a light word it's
that's true you're like you're an
acquaintance it's like friendship takes
whatever but i would teach you how to do
that well you could do my workshop you i
would love that because you talk about
it in your stand-up which is so good by
the way um it's called our uh our man in
chicago jeff garland it's on netflix
it's so good but i think one of the
reasons your humor and you really appeal
to me is because you get into certain
situations which is also why you're
great on curb that i
can completely relate to i and you talk
about one i won't like make you rehash
that
your special your stories though you're
such a good storyteller and i
i'd like you to but but you get into a
sin altercation which escalates with a
woman that when i get arrested ugh it
made me laugh it caught me by surprise
and like i say in the special i thought
i'm 50 some 50 years old i go
watching colombo and the guy get
arrested i go and just randomly i don't
think i'm ever going to get arrested and
then lo and behold a week later i'm
arrested
but because you're of it you're at a
certain age we're like what am i going
to do to get at this point yeah well by
the way also my nature yeah what am i
going to do and i learned a lot from the
experience and
and it was a very relatable experience
because it could have happened to anyone
totally totally and they also dropped
the charges the next day but nonetheless
it was horrifying and it actually put
the final stake in my marriage yeah you
say that too
which is crazy which but but it's a
situation which sounds like i'm
it it sounds like it started in a more
dramatic fashion but it started in a way
that
i've been in so many situations similar
to that where somebody does something on
the road i mean you're in your car
certainly in l.a and
what always amazes me is when it's
clearly somebody else's fault i've been
having this experience where
people are texting i always see people
texting in the car and i see them on the
highway veering into my lane yes so i
give a little friendly and they talk
about this on curb like a little like
pop-up like a little afraid like i'm not
mad at you i just want to let you know
you're coming into my line and i've
gotten
stared finger [ __ ] you you know yeah and
for what i'm trying to like by the way
that's the ego central no no no
ego's about
having other people's opinions directly
affect you in a deep way because you're
so shallow with that which is what this
woman in florida did to me and which
this woman in the parking lot
is there a way to tell it because now i
feel like people are hearing us talk
about it no justin there isn't
see i just set up boundaries with yeah
whoa that's good i just set up
boundaries i i could have gone yeah i'll
tell you yeah yeah and it's a
bastardized version yeah no one watches
my stuff that's true i want every one of
your listeners to watch my speech that's
true that's smart and the story you
learn about life from the story that's
true and you laugh at me the appropriate
person to laugh at in my stories i'm the
stupid one i am low status and that is
the only way to be that's not
necessarily true for comedy comedy low
status if you're the fool right it's
funny that's right when you're the cool
one it ain't funny when you fail at the
cool one you're low status yes yeah i
remember yeah i remember adam sandler
once he said to me because i saw that
movie out there you know he goes yeah
buddy your body looked like you were
working out and i did i worked out for
him my vanity got the better of me and
he goes you got to get a comedy body
buddy and he said what do you mean he's
like you can't be like have muscles and
stuff and we want to laugh at it yeah
but you can't have like muscles yeah
yeah you can't that's fine it's just
it's it's there's a a vulnerability
that's lacking when you're too fit
so and i told him i said this so i don't
want to look back like i'm bad mouthing
the guy
but dane cook's arms are really [ __ ]
big
and i followed him recently in la and i
went up and i said to the arts i go i'm
sorry his arms are too big for comedy it
got the biggest laugh he laughed when i
told him you know it's because it's true
kind of true you cannot
that's why carrot top has always been a
weird one
i mean you know look there's so many
things going on in the character oh
that's why he's been a weird one no i
mean in terms of uh visually the way his
eyes are and and the the body which is
so muscular yeah it's strange it's
distracting you met him he said what it
would very well be dude totally nice
nice man yeah but i i don't know him
well but visually there's a lot going on
there that i think is distracting that's
why i guess it doesn't distract from
prop comedy like big stuff like he does
but if he was telling stories
i don't know who could focus i know i'd
be hard to get past right yeah because
you'd be like what's going on
yeah
yeah
yeah you uh speaking of
physical transformations yeah you and
since the last time i saw you have
you've lost the concealer
at least
well i was gonna say you got a haircut i
lost like 70 pounds i was gonna say you
lost a lot of hairs you got a haircut
um no you must be sick of talking about
your weight loss no no i'm not sick of
it it's just that i want to save for the
record i've nev i've not dieted and my
weight loss it was very slow i just was
more thoughtful with how i approached
food sugar i stopped eating sugar like
sweets yeah i mean there's sugar in food
sometimes you you don't know oh so
you're not like and i'll eat fruit but
but i'll even eat watermelon you know i
don't care so but um
in terms of sweets like it's been years
since i've had a cookie or ice cream oh
god and ice cream is the thing that you
said is yours
proof for the existence of god you said
yeah chocolate chip i don't see how you
can say there is no god yeah yeah that's
funny i i i'm trying not to now rehash
things in your special but also i heard
you on it's all good
it's it is so good but it's also it will
not go anywhere you go yeah thanks buddy
yeah well i'm gonna repeat the arrest
story okay okay my boundary it's a tease
and i'm not gonna go say hello to your
people no good all right
her people her people yeah that's
disturbing i don't have any so you're in
luck um i but i also heard you talk
about this on on dax's podcast and it's
it's something that it it's you also
talk about on the special and it was
enlightening because i had never thought
of
i i never thought of food in terms of
something that you could be addicted to
and i know and i know i've heard of you
know i know people are but i i never
heard it articulated in the way that
makes you know how i lost my weight i'm
going to tell you the secret
i sit with my feelings
when i feel something i don't go for
a candy bar a cookie ice cream
i don't i sit with my feelings and that
that has led to because feelings are
temporary yeah they can be a few minutes
they can unfortunately be a week or so
where you're just mixed up but not much
longer than that so when you in in the
past when you had a feeling what about
bad oh really or bad i went for oreos or
whatever oh really like after sex
instead of a cigarette oh my god yeah
really oh yeah
and and it elevates your it's uh
i wanted to get i wanted to numb me out
you know i don't want to feel anything
unfortunately after a period of time the
food no longer does that
like
you know any other thing stops yeah it
just stops working well because you your
threshold is so high is it because
there's that but there's also it just
doesn't do the magic it's not magical
anymore it's just this
it just makes my body feel bad so when
you miss it now like when you talk about
missing ice cream is it is it purely the
i mean obviously is it just the taste is
it the the ice cream is a sensation
that's the point ice cream it's it's a
sensation it's a taste it's a feeling
when you're done yeah it doesn't feel
bad
that's true you know
no i and i of course have a strong
memory of all of it i just can't do it
god and um
that's the one i miss everyone asks is
that how do you do it and i can do it
but there are times where i'm like oh
ice cream yeah that would be so cool
yeah i never pined for a cupcake even
though i loved cupcakes and all that
stuff even when you're around and when
you see people oh it means nothing
you could even be eating ice cream and i
wouldn't necessarily pine for ice cream
it just happens sometimes i'm okay with
it i i go to a dinner party they serve
dessert i don't eat dessert but everyone
eating dessert meat means nothing and
you said it took about two weeks for
that two weddings for this yes two weeks
of hell yeah and then it's cool and then
you just gotta keep going so is there
like any other addiction i mean like in
the movies when they do the montage when
they're getting off heroin and they're
like yeah i would say it's a similar
thing wow i don't know the heroine
that's pretty harrowing yeah yeah
what was your f not to dwell on it but
what was your flavor what was like the
oh baby so funny people asked me that
and what if i told you vanilla
chocolate chip which is vanilla with
chocolate chips in it um
but man i love every ice cream mint chip
strawberry chocolate you know i i rocky
road i loved ice cream all of it but my
favorite is actually the simplest one
and not french vanilla which i enjoyed
with a little regular vanilla we have
vanilla bean if you want from a specific
place would you well no i enjoyed any
good ice cream yeah enjoy i mean look i
enjoyed
ralph's ice cream yeah but that's not as
good as
even uh haagen-dazs or you're carvel
yeah all that yes i used to work at a
carvel and i developed lactose
intolerance i think because i ate so
much by the way i had a friend who
worked at carmel and i used to go there
and fill up you know the those chocolate
chip thingies sure that you put in the
cake i would mix them up i love fudgy
the whale i've been more [ __ ] away
that was the most disgusting voice on tv
monday is sunday
wednesday no i know that's why you
talked but
i i i gotta tell you i've had numerous
on my own in one sitting fudgie the
whales i've gone in a car valve wow and
i would even say oh got a big party and
then i'd take it home i would take home
my fudge of the whale and eat it oh
in one sitting in one sitting yep oh my
god
and so okay after you're done walk me
through the sensation that you feel what
what do you or like you said you just
feel
well by the way as i
i i talked about this and also in the
special in terms of when i would eat all
those doughnuts yeah robocop three you
said 36 i was trying to remember was
that the riptorn robocop no oh no no no
no it was after wait but what you were
saying when you were eating the donuts
you tell a story about eating like 36
donuts
so you know but with me what i
discovered later on was i would start
getting high
when i say hi like
in the days and then extraordinarily
tired oh my god so i need fudgy the
whale and fall asleep wow
and i was like yeah because i didn't
have any anxiety or pain i'd fall asleep
but then i wake up with
way more anxiety than i had in the first
place and self-loathing i mean
self-loathing yeah oh
that's a partner of over-reading they're
good friends god yeah no it was all it
was it was tragic but the thing about
uh sugar unlike um heroin
sugar it's not a fast death
you don't see a lot of old fat guys yes
that's the truth yeah so at some point
it cuts your life yeah whereas uh you
know heroin you're you're you can be in
perfect shape and be dead yeah do you uh
and so now are do you have more of a
cliff do you notice the difference i
mean just in general by the way when you
go off sugar and i'm not talking about
anybody for me though yeah it was like a
couple things the world is way clearer
than when i'm eating sugar and it's like
someone energy wise put a rocket up my
ass oh i bet i got tons of energy and i
see things clear now
yeah yeah and i have for a long time now
wow yeah yeah i started eating i i got
on this regimen of eating um uh just
vegetable juice like
this smoothies with just mostly
vegetables a little fruit in the morning
and it completely changed my life i used
to get uh after breakfast especially at
work
my energy was just
i couldn't function i mean i could
barely change ah completely i mean it
really transformed my life vegetables
are a pretty great yeah i mean they're
not my delight in terms of i want to
have vegetables but what they do to you
it's delightful what now in terms of
food in terms of like a culinary treat
really right have any culinary treatment
really look at it as a treat oh
interesting i mean i have pizza every
now and again yeah but none of it's a
treat if i look at it as a treat then
it's an addiction oh and it's a problem
yeah
whereas i just use common sense and if i
have pizza it has nothing to do with the
next meal i'm gonna have if i have ice
cream
forget next meal i'm not even going to
make it to the next meal i'm going to
have more ice cream and then cookies
it'll just be it'll be over yeah yeah do
you so you don't smoke we you don't know
we do do yes i do smoke weed i started
at
wow whoopi goldberg i did the view
she turned me on to how it could help me
i was talking to her about anxiety lack
of sleep oh you really want to calm down
yeah i know and she turned me on to
indica
which has been a lifesaver but what i
also noticed about me in smoking weed
i can go two three months and not smoke
any weed and not even think about it
like forget
so well no i don't have a problem but
that's not impressed as impressive to me
is the fact that you can smoke weed and
not
crave some sort of snack oh no actually
it does not have that effect wow
amazing it does not have that effect on
me i only am hungry when i'm hungry i
can smoke all the wheat i want and it
doesn't affect how hungry i am wow god
god bless you
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
again we'll meet again
[Music]
but you grew up in chicago yeah what did
your parents do
my dad
had a family business a plumbing supply
and my mother was a mother
but early on she was a studying to be an
actress and she's an artist
yeah so she oh she had aspirations yes
and she gave it all up when she had my
brother and i
my mom's similar vicariously through me
my mother she did so was she encouraging
of you when you said you wanted to get
into it
yes and no because you were young i'm
very confused but it's also
look
being a comedian if you said in 1940 to
your parents you're going to be a
comedian
go do whatever
1980s
you're a jew what you're not going to be
a lawyer you're not going to be a doctor
but something's wrong yeah if you want
to be a comedian yeah but yet i was the
funniest in school my whole life it's
what i was meant to do and wanted to do
and they recognized that i'm sure you're
no
i got a well here's what they wanted
they both wanted me to have something to
fall back on right it was a big deal to
them i bet have to have something to
fall back on and i got to tell you when
you have something to fall back on
uh
you're probably going to fall back on it
yeah
difficult the only thing that i would
recommend anyone to fall back on is an
education yeah because then you're a
smart well-rounded person and i wish i
would have gotten a liberal arts degree
but i quit and focused completely on
comedy well especially for what you do
what what made you
you know known is you need to be sharp
you need to be quick in order to yes
very much so yeah respond to somebody
like like larry david i love what you
said to
people coming up to you and saying
you had asked larry you said how many
times did somebody come up here
because everyone comes to me goes what's
larry david really like and one day
i said to him i go i'm going to ask you
i've never has anyone ever come up to
you and said what's jeff gremlin really
like you no no never happened
well that's what i love so much about
your special and
about about because i don't know you
well i've been around just a little bit
but i your special was so enlightening
and that i got to know this person that
i only really knew through the lens of
larry you know but my special really
shows people who i am yeah when you're
done watching you know who i am it's
great
and it's i hope absolutely and it's
somebody that i really enjoyed hanging
out with for that hour and and wasn't as
familiar as i thought i was you know
people i'm sure people come to you think
they know you and of you get it of
course yeah yeah so it's all okay yeah
um we had jb's move on and i had a
similar revelation about him i was like
oh this is a different person i very
much really only know him he is the best
guy ever the best i love him and again
like [ __ ] quick i mean in order to
him so much and a similar sense of i
asked him about his audition process for
curb and and
i would ask you the same thing was there
how were you nervous to interact with
larry you you knew him i think better
than jb so i conceived the show and i
approached larry oh right so it was his
idea to have me
wow play his manager and then he just i
went with an idea to larry to larry
david and he ran with it oh my god i
went to a genius and when i hear i got
this idea and the junior said all right
oh i got it wow yeah boom
and so but jb's audition i was in the
room oh you were i was in the room when
he auditioned and he came in a day early
from when we were looking at for his
part oh he didn't he was so great
that we cancelled a lot of auditions
that we kept a few that we couldn't
cancel yeah but he was amazing wow it
was clear well he had said i said well
you must have been nervous no
no i knew it was mine i knew you know he
wasn't nervous at all it's amazing it
was but when it's meant to be it's meant
to be yeah just as it was meant to be i
i'm fascinated by that because i think
i've i have so especially people i
respect and and i know he respected
larry in the show going in so
the fact that he wouldn't and that's and
he was only supposed to be on for a
season oh oh this season where they uh
he takes in the family yeah they're
called
and um
he was just so damn funny and he wasn't
going to keep the black family as the
story was going to marry and all the
stuff yeah so he um
the black family went on their way and
and leon stayed living with larry yeah i
love that they don't have to have
leon as a roommate is hilarious and i
love that they don't really explain it
any more than like
aren't you going and he's like no man
i'm staying here and he's like okay well
there's that's kind of don't need it
it's
not necessary it's amazing yeah
you um you you lived you lived in
florida throughout high school
yeah
i'm from chicago we moved to florida
when i was in sixth grade and then i
left florida at 22 to
move to chicago to do second city and
stand up
i started in comedy in florida okay so
you did you you referenced a movie the
movie spring break yeah which was when i
was in florida she shot that there i
shot that there when i was 19 i went in
to be uh in this movie yeah and you talk
about belly flop so was that when you
got a movie like that i mean they were
making a lot of movies like that back in
the years right yeah that was the day of
like you know the uh one crazy summer
boy yeah yeah yeah what did you feel
like when you got that where your
parents certainly must have felt like oh
this he's in a movie no no because i was
here's the thing
back then in florida if you had an agent
you paid your agent like 25 registration
fee absurd
and then like every year another 25
whatever
they told me
that i had a part in this movie spring
break i show up i'm an extra
well
someone the director points at me and
goes i want him to do this belly flop
thing and so i do this thing but they
still didn't give me any lines i have no
lines i have close-ups oh i growl i
smash bear cans in my head i shoot a
moon and i do these belly flips and i
really did my own belly flops which is
only a 20 year old skills yeah that's
our 19th century
yeah but i beg them i really was like
why don't you have me do some lines like
give me make my part something you know
they know no
then the dvd comes out and i'm the only
person that they talk about in this so
far yeah because i went on to yeah
success was there anybody else in the
movie that continued uh
a lot of working actors but nobody was
really working that much anymore so very
nice people and so then and by the way
the lead actors the two fellas
the sweet guys i cannot remember their
names they're really nice guys
they remembered me as an extra in the
how often do you remember extras
i developed like a nice thing with them
they really they could have i'm not
going to say they should have they could
have really
done something with me yeah what's funny
is they could have yeah and they didn't
but
the idea that they used me to market the
movie when it comes out on dvd i found
hallelujah that's funny and that and
also the fact that now knowing how sharp
and a comedic brain you have an instinct
that you have to just use you as a
physical piece of comedy that's all it
was that's so funny yeah so when you go
back to chicago it's like this is what
now i know what my
i know what i want to pursue fully uh oh
yeah i know i knew i know you knew that
i knew i knew when i was and i'm like
not making this up
i knew when i was a little kid when i
was eight years old my parents
didn't want to see jimmy durante
okay so they took me to see him perform
wow after the show on the way home i
asked my parents is that a job they said
yes i said that's the job that i want i
was eight and what did they say do you
remember they chuckled yeah yeah i mean
you could say things yeah uh and so
but i knew i was the funniest kid in
school and i knew it's what i wanted to
do i knew for sure when i saw the blues
brothers oh staring at live had a big
influence the original for sure but then
when i saw the blues brothers i kept
saying to people i'm on a mission from
god you know
and that was like i was doing it i was
gonna i was gonna be the next john
pollution yeah yeah so you so second
city is where you go to do that i mean
that makes perfect sense i was a huge sc
tv fan oh yeah yeah yeah so yeah and and
was that and how long were you there and
was that where you was there for a long
time
on and off got fired quit all this stuff
you know and was doing stand up at the
same time why fight why fire
have fire
you know back then
uh
the audience it's it's really kind of an
interesting thing
as i was developing i'm a young man in
my 20s
second city when i went out on stage
with the ensemble the audience loved me
and laughed at everything i said however
my peers not much respect
in stand up my peers respected me and
audiences were completely confused by me
oh weird so i had that it all came
together eventually yeah but as you're
developing it's kind of interesting and
so the people say nobody ever mixed them
so my second city
compadres would say just go do stand-up
you don't need to be here oh i didn't
realize till later there was issues with
primary personality too but but just
there was jealousy there was different
things did they
yeah like you surfing a scene do they
feel like you were you were dominating
yeah they definitely did and um what's
fun for me is all the people who were
mean to me at second city i hired as
actors on curb oh no kidding yeah oh
that's kind of great i'm talking about
by the way the letting go of ego
the greatest revenge is to be kind and
thoughtful to people who weren't that
way to you yes like there's people in
the stand-up world who were crappy to me
when i was a young comedian and i'm only
extraordinarily nice to them the joy in
it is that everyone thinks that you
forget yeah don't forget but i don't
hold the bitterness man it's all good
you just reprocess it reprocess it into
kindness
that means next time i go to florida i
gotta invite lorraine out to the twitter
lady
by the way i grew up you know plantation
thought that's why i started comedy in
fort lauderdale i had a movie played the
four letter little film festival i
couldn't go years ago i wanted someone
to eat cheese with
but yeah absolutely yes right south
florida's got some winners
no they really do yeah i like it a lot
when i was a kid
like literally a little kid in south
florida it was
you know um
sleepy
alligators yeah you know beaches it was
palmetto but but it was not
built up
and yeah what i always say about los
angeles
you know because it's warm and south
florida's warm at least when people come
to la they come with a dream
south florida they basically go there
just to get rid of bad weather right so
you've got people without you just
staggering just stagnating people that
you don't want to meet yeah that's
interesting so that's why i love going
down there very much i don't anymore uh
well i mean i've changed it
yet it did i i it's been
i think it's been
it's been a long time since i've been
and i i hesitate to
even think about how it must have must
be changed are you are your folks still
there my parents are both dead thank you
what kind of [ __ ] show is this sorry
no you might know that i didn't know
that why didn't i say no no no no no i
mean in spirit jeff my mom died a couple
years ago and my dad died a few years
before that and um yeah it happens i'm
sorry by the way in one year
my mom died i got divorced and my dogs
died that's right yeah i talked about
that in this business
yeah that's which i just saw and i just
asked you that question uh what a right
man well it's so ripe for comedy that
but it probably is oh it always yeah
everything life is i the only thing i
wrote about my parents death was
not as much about my dad but my mother
that i don't ever want to see her ghost
i don't want to like contact her you
know people like have seances you know i
think about that my parents are alive
but i think about that well i don't want
i don't want her
i saw how many bananas you ate yesterday
you don't need that many one or two
you had three bananas yeah you know what
my mom hated bananas
well
i don't know what happened whether it
was a penis or whether it was a duty i
don't know what it is about a banana
she hated i swear to god bananas
this was it and my children who got to
know my mom well
uh she hated i swear growing up bananas
she rarely had bananas in the house she
hated frankenstein's monster she was
terrified of frankenstein
and are you ready for this this is the
best one of the three johnny cash
who i couldn't love more
uh ellie was alive i told her how did
you eliminate johnny cash for my life i
loved that man he hated his music or his
music his persona the man in black
because she likes sound of music in that
[ __ ] so johnny cash represented the
opposite so i used to i used to do
things like when i borrowed her car
get a johnny cash
and when she got in it was ring of fire
you know
but my boys would go grandma house
frankenstein like they had fun they'd
play it up yeah yeah and she god bless
her she'd laugh grammar you want a
banana yeah yeah uh yeah you that's such
a funny combination of three and was she
and was she known to was she cynic would
she a malcontent about other things no
that's so funny those are the three
things she didn't like when people
weren't nice huh
that they're he's not a nice person yeah
and when she was she said she also had a
thing about the new yorkers come down
here
you know and so i was from chicago right
yeah i didn't you know in south florida
i didn't understand what she meant you
know some new yorkers there's a bit of a
personality yeah but me i've i've lived
in new york new york is one of my
favorite places on earth people probably
mistake you for a new yorker
yeah all the time um so for me also to
not only have prejudice against johnny
cash but to think that new yorkers are
jerks right right it was like what
they're not you know learning these
things later on like why did you do that
yeah it'd be funny it's true and now and
her seeing well you couldn't listen to
johnny cash or eat bananas but also like
i think about that with ghosts sometimes
uh you know and also them observing your
any kind of sexual behavior i yeah and i
believe in ghosts you do oh yeah i
believe in
i believe in every all the all that
stuff fascinated by it i am i love going
on the ghost tours and i've met i i've
come across ghosts really the best one
was probably the funniest one
i know many ghosts i have ghosts this is
my next question who was the funniest
ghost you met oh
but anyhow so i'm doing a movie in um
seattle uh-huh and uh
first day of filming i'm in my room
going to sleep tired
but i'm reading uh i think it was a
comic book you know my head on my pillow
uh uh
light you know
uh and then reading my comic book and
all of a sudden the covers come off my
feet in bed
and i look up like for a fan i'm like
well how did that just happen
okay whenever i cover my feet a minute
later whoosh off my feet no wind from
anywhere and i just burst out laughing
and i go are you kidding me
because it clearly wasn't it didn't feel
and i said all right i'll keep them off
my feet
just can i read and then go to bed i
keep my feet and i did
so the next morning
uh i go down to the front desk and i go
i gotta ask you it's this hotel on
haunted
and they said room but is and i go
that's my room i'll go who wants it this
lady she sometimes is seen in the
hallway she used to have a foot fetish i
don't know but i don't know what it was
but yeah it was and i've read about it
online no [ __ ] yeah and that and it and
it didn't scare you when did you you
know
so absurd right
it wasn't like a feeling of cold or
violence yeah
there was nothing exciting
it was hilarious i found it's the ghost
i believe in ghosts and i'm cool with
ghosts you know what i mean and maybe
they don't know things in the world that
i don't want to mess with but most
ghosts i think are just hanging out life
could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
so in terms of the afterlife you believe
that like oh there's this realm there's
a world by the way you're you're you're
taking it a step further i have no clue
i have no clue as to what they have how
many people become ghosts who's a
friendly ghost who's not i don't know i
don't i don't have any opinions about
any of that but i do think that there is
something okay well that's yeah that's
more than a lot of people that you know
that's kind of cool yeah um and you
believe in ice cream and sex so i
believe as you say i believe it hardly
an ice cream sandwich got to be a god
ice cream has stopped but as long as sex
doesn't stop i'm okay yeah god that's
i'm jealous of you i wish i'm fascinated
by the idea of ghosts and i would love
in interaction with one uh
you you talk about it in the special um
some really bad gigs that you had i mean
every oh i mean you're the thing is
when i look back on it they depressed me
they made me sad when i'd bomb or
bad things happen to me but i look back
and it was all adversely it was all part
of the journey and they're crazy
about their amazing amazing stories yeah
did you ever think about where their
moments though i was thinking this
listening to them did you ever think
about
quitting i mean was it did they get that
quitting many times huh
many times but i had no choice had
nothing to fall back on yeah and i just
kept moving forward but by the way
not in those bad gigs where i was like
oh this will make a great story but when
i got arrested
i truly thought to myself well let's see
what happens because this is a story
yeah this is a story yeah and also
i made it work out when i went
the charges were dropped against me but
i can't like give the details but i can
tell you there was a civil suit brought
about oh my god
i know but it was all once she found out
who i was point being
it's fine but i had to pay her some
money you know i knew i knew i was going
to and i wasn't i wasn't i really wasn't
upset well i wasn't upset but listen to
this yeah
part of the deal was
when she signed the accepting of the
money and the terms that i could do it
in my stand up oh that's just great i
couldn't name her and i don't never know
but i also can't say where she's from so
your id it was your idea you brought the
idea to larry for curb how did you know
larry before that just through the
comedians
and also i was writing
i was writing with alan zweibel who's a
great writer yeah and billy crystal was
there wrote ghost world right oh allen's
white bell what did he well he created
its gary shandling show oh god he wrote
all of gilda radner stuff for
um when you were falling in love with us
now yeah that's really cool exactly and
he was a writer on the show then wow and
i love alan's white bell he's a great
man but he shared an office with billy
crystal and larry david and larry and i
would talk every day wow about our kids
and different things and yeah we were
acquaintances and he asked me the lunch
one day and he and i went to lunch and
at lunch i said you know if you ever
want to do a special here's an idea i
have and hbo had approached him
and then we went to pitch it to hbo
harry emanuel larry david myself to
chris albrecht and chris albrecht said
the words how can i not do this oh yeah
are you kidding me smart how can i not
do this yeah then the first day of
filming you know larry and i as we
prepared the show
realized that we had this weird we've
been comedy
uh partners for a long time there was
this weird connection yeah like
chemistry and so first day of filming he
said to me oh what if we did this as a
series because it was a one-off yeah
yeah it was a one-off and i my thought
process was yeah i'll be on larry
david's next series yeah little did i
know so that's jesus christ that's just
20 years ago yesterday 20 years ago how
much of that then is you just when he
had that idea hey we should do this how
much of it was you just being i mean i
know all acting is just being present
but
how much of it was just being there
versus playing some part playing the
role of a manager i i don't i don't i
don't look at it as i play the partner
literally
i know what the scene's about and i just
do it but yeah which is what i think
about it which is what all acting should
be
everyone approaches it differently for
example i'm not a good enough actor to
rise above bad material i know that
about myself whereas like ed norton who
you mentioned yeah ed norton my fellow
[ __ ] okay no but norton is
you give him anything and ed norton's
[ __ ] great right and norton is a
spectacular actor right i am not i am as
good as the material i've been given
it's funny i was just talking about this
with my brother because we're both
fascinated by hallmark christmas movies
we love the you know lifetime i know by
the way uh my friend steve
is obsessed with them too yeah they're
the best but i and i always wonder like
if i had a script like that would i be
able to write would i could i do it and
make it make it natural i that would be
a real test by the way that so would be
like i wasn't villain on baywatch once
ah and i i say it's my best acting and
worst acting yeah because hey i'm not
good enough to rise above bad materials
i said however i had scenes with david
hasselhoff i was the villain and he was
yelling at me as mitch you know the
character
and i didn't laugh
good act good freaking amazing the best
and worst acting yes but it would be a
good test you in a hallmark movie
coming off as natural that's a good test
for you it's true it's a good test for
it should be fun wouldn't that be fun oh
yeah totally fun but also you you could
possibly suck up the joint which would
fit in with the show totally yeah either
way you win the way you win um one more
question then i gotta go to a speed run
because i know you have to go which
sucks because this is so fun it's an
honor man um mine is my honor and by the
way for people who don't know we did do
a movie yeah strange wilderness we're
gonna my brother and i are gonna talk
about that but my memories of it and you
are just loving being around you
a great time that whole section
but by the way that's the way i approach
everything i do with joy
you know and i was happy for those guys
getting that movie made wow other snl
writers fred wolfe yeah so and also the
feeling of like this is so fun yeah it's
just so stupid
yeah your outtakes are great that's
right there's nothing that i the the
happiest i am i think is when i'm
watching
outtakes really fun outtakes and you can
see somebody's joy in doing this is that
a ball years are great uh and steve zahn
might be the most talented man on earth
i agree talk about an actor who can rise
above bad material yes i remember doing
that
i also i was in daddy daycare with him
and i remember doing off-camera work and
getting so lost in his performance that
i would forget to say my lines i believe
that i was like wow you are amazing
anyone who wants to see great comedic
acting safe men is i think is one of the
best been out of sight out of sight he's
a member of this riding cars with boys
he should have mark he should have won
an oscar for well by the way he will he
will yeah someday he's so good and he's
the nicest i love that
yeah what a great move last question
before we get into that our speed round
um
how do you go i've been so curious about
this how do you go from having all the
freedom that you have on curb and
everyone kind of knows how that show
works it's just uh very
improv oriented and there's a skeleton
for the scenes how do you go from that
to doing a scripted show like the
goldbergs is it
this term like the goldbergs yeah what i
mean but that is sometimes you'll do a
scripted show and it's the [ __ ]
sopranos and like you just you just you
know as patty chayefsky wrote something
you go i'm going to say every but i
learned my lines thoroughly they want me
to on the goldbergs i got to say i'm
going to use the word stifling it's very
stifling i bet but but i've given it's
it's all good yeah it was very hard at
first
now it's much easier
what do you attribute that to just
understanding the work and my job is to
be as an actor i'm a storyteller my job
is to tell the story they want so it's
my job to do the goldbergs the way it's
supposed to be done
yeah you know yeah as opposed to
goldbergs is more about craft
and curb is more about the art
i have to resort to my craft to figure
out how to i have to i know by the way
i'm of the spencer tracy school of
acting know your lines and don't bump
into the furniture i love yeah that's
that's totally my approach and i just do
it you know and so that's what i do but
there is also the i got to figure out
how to do this scene
besides learning my lines and just
saying it
to you know make sure to tell your story
but but i understand the stifling
element knowing that you have such a
comedic well guess
yeah yeah yeah it's so joyful um okay
short questions uh
uh what is your most commonly used emoji
when you text if you use them
uh i don't i don't actually
my friend
my friend liz
does
uh she always uses the the woman with
the hands up like i don't know oh no
no no
like who's to say yeah i don't she has
her daughter and i left she just uses
the [ __ ] out of it um but in terms of me
i don't have one that i go to okay i
have this emoji where it's sort of like
a a little cartoony me with a cubs hat
oh yeah and it just depends on the
situation okay blowing heart
yeah i like the blood jumping up and
down you know whatever it is yeah that's
so funny i thought i have no overused
emoji okay all right uh um if you could
be a professional athlete you played uh
i played all sports
what would you play if you could be a if
i could be like in the in my prime yeah
professional athlete i would want to be
a baseball player for the cubs yeah for
the cubs yeah sure
like sammy sosa um it's not like sammy
if you could have one snack oh well i
think i know this now your snack food do
you do you have a snack food that you
can go to
not really sorry i like it by the way i
love a delicious apple okay yeah fuji
apple nice fuji apple crisp
honey crisp i mean yeah i love apples
dried out
yeah i don't eat dried apples because
generally i have a lot of sugar
concentrated sugar yep um what's your
favorite movie of all time hmm
boy that's a that's a tough one
i would get it it's between
it's a wonderful life and sullivan's
travels i've never seen sullivan's
travels oh i want to very important okay
preston sturgis okay it's a masterpiece
it's it's a movie that goes between
uh uh drama
uh
regular comedy and broad comedy yeah and
it really works it's remarkable
screwball
but it's got a great message yeah i'd
say those two movies so jeff you got me
thinking about spencer tracy now and one
of my great delights in watching the
movies like those hallmark movies and
and movies and i've done it myself i'm
really bad at is seeing actors look for
their marks you know and i spencer tracy
apparently was a master at doing that he
would always incorporate it into a
gesture uh yeah oh you know he would no
he was natural yeah don't bump into the
furniture i like know where your mark is
i like that and you by the way marks are
difficult sometimes totally on [ __ ] i
catch myself
here's what i here's what i can tell you
yeah here's what i do now i look at the
mark when i'm you know the rehearsal
whatever yeah and then they
reconfirm the mark yeah then i forget
about it and you know what happens
90 percent of time i hit my mark
and when i don't they go oh you missed
your mark okay
and i go where is it and then the next
time you're going to get it anyhow
showing you again yeah it's true so i
just forget about that's what i that's
my actually my approach to stand up and
acting is to trust that i'm present yeah
that's it well i i would say your
special is an example of that i mean
it's a really glowing example that uh if
you could have dinner with uh three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met this might be a tough one and we've
gone back never met yeah
jeez
i don't i i'm naturally curious about
everything yeah but i don't have that
list okay uh you could live somewhere
else where would it be besides
that felonious monk
would be one of the people i'd want to
just
be probably like a bunch of old blues or
jazz yeah
yeah uh if you could live one other
place
aside from l.a oh i love l.a
one other place i guess if i had to pick
i'd pick new york okay uh who's your
favorite muppet
um kermit okay
um if you could have won superpower what
would it be
uh hindsight
i wouldn't have done this podcast
no no it's like imagine if any situation
you're about to enter you know the you
know the results great yeah that's a
superpower yeah i have a super power
being funny is a super i look at his i
tell my boys use your humor for good
and it will never fail you with great
comedic power yes great great
responsibility um if you could be one
age for the rest of your life physically
were you you just feel like you could
live that age
um how old am i right now 57 57 okay
that's a great answer uh inspiring
answer if you could uh be reincarnated
as a non-human animal what what what
would it be not human animal yeah as an
anima you don't have to need to add
non-us i know that's true it's a
redundant yeah so animal if i could come
back as an animal i'd want to come back
as
i don't know
well that's a mammal i was gonna say
dolphin i want to be something in the
sea i might be a fish which is not an
animal
um if you were asked a redundant
question would you point out that it was
redundant always yes
because there's nothing personal again
yeah of course they're correct so you
know to not do that every time it's like
oh i was doing that it's like having a
booger and no one tells you ah yeah just
like amen right there i swear it's the
mark of a real friend
but yeah you're genuine i i told so i
was doing a play in high school and i
said to one of the kids i won't say his
name i said you know your breath is
really
it's really pungent it's really horrible
and and he appreciated it he started
brushing his teeth before by the way i
couldn't stand it by the way how many
times and you know you pointed out
something there and it's not as much
with adults with bad breath although we
do go back to
high school and whatever like not
telling people but
more than anything youth is cruel
because people will kids will be cruel
to one another but no one's gonna say to
a kid
you know that shirt that you keep
wearing it just it looks terrible and
you smell yeah yeah i mean i mean
there's a way to say that with
compassion with compassion by the way
anything can be said with compassion
yeah if
i i
hate that you gotta go but if you were a
ghost um if you were if that happened to
you yeah
how would you use that how what would
you do like if you were in that hotel
room with you um would you by the way
first off my ghost approach is this
you be stereotypical
youth i'd get away with if it weren't
for you damn kids that's what i was
using like a scooby-doo
ghost yeah no i i don't know what my
thing would be i would just i would
leave people alone yeah or by the way i
do have to say if you're a ghost pulling
sheets off someone's feet is fun it is
funny oh yeah i would do that too uh
beetles or stones rolling stones uh
boy that's tough because it's different
things but i would say beetles
um
what what would you want your epitaph to
read do you think about that do you
think no i don't ever think about that
and then i'll talk about that good
that's the right answer honey yeah salon
goes how would you like to be remembered
i go oh so you have a death show for me
so when
you know did
i mean that's like they've got a whole
collection at salon of people saying how
they want to be remembered which they're
gonna use right [ __ ] die
no i don't in memoriam i'm just happy to
be here yeah well i'm happy that's my
epitaph i'm happy to be here i'm happy
you're here too and and that could apply
if you are a ghost yeah uh as well happy
ghost i'm so happy you're here i was so
good to see you again i can't believe
it's been so long it's weird i feel like
but you live here now i live here i'm
going to be in la but i but let's keep
in touch because i it's weird i feel i
watch i watch curbs so often and i eat
multiple multiple times it's like
hanging out with a friend i think that i
feel like you know that i dig you so
that's i made that apparent
in our past uh connections you have yeah
so yeah i'll hang out with you anytime
so make mark this yeah
when we became friends okay on your
podcast this is the we went from
acquaintances to actual friends and when
you come to la now we have to hang out
okay now you have a responsibility
now i'm obligated you are great they're
friends
contact their friend when they're in
town that's you are you okay the guilt
has started already all right uh this is
this is a good obligation and uh it's
the new star wars movie you're in i am
but it's it's been overplayed i'm not
going to ask you about it no i'm an
extra i'm an extrovert
the pictures that are online are not
real belly flops there's no belly flare
okay but i was in four hours of makeup
jj's a great friend of mine and um i
love the guy so i went and i spent why
not there figuring out which day i'd
even work they know it's like last and
then i was four hours in makeup becoming
an alien i'm the only alien in the scene
i'm in you'll know who i am
and there's two shots they're both still
in the movie oh your kids are gonna get
a kick out of it yeah everyone will oh
yeah
when we're off the air i'm gonna show
you a picture okay oh great okay all
right thanks buddy all right thank you
awesome go watch strange wilderness
again yeah cause i'm sure you've already
seen it we have smoked some wheat yeah
that's what it's for
[Music]
well that happens well that happens
swell that happened
uh it happened and i
you know when he was when he was saying
goodbye he um
first of all the people that were with
him were so nice he was you can really
tell
somebody's true nature when like after
the show you know when we stopped
recording and
he's just such a men she's such a
lovable like
sweet guy um and he was so nice to the
people that
you know his publicist and his assistant
but he said uh i don't know if there's
gonna be an interesting story he put he
said we gotta hang out now because we
were talking about that in the interview
and he said he gave me his number he or
he called me i gave him my number and he
called me and i didn't realize
afterwards i realized my phone was off
so i never got his number
so i never got to text him afterwards oh
my god what a terrible story no that's a
great story
that really sums up the interview
all right well what did she think of it
did you end up getting his
uh yeah but i had to get it through the
wonder people
yeah i should we should save that for oh
my god
uh you talked about hugging him and and
you're like oh it's so fun nice to hug
you yeah and it's he seems like someone
who would be a great hugger oh like
someone fun to hug you know what though
was he a good hugger this might speaking
of that this actually might be worth
telling uh unlike the last thing i said
he he when i did hug him he was he's
like a big bear of a guy you know you
know him
physically like what he looks like and
he
he kind of yeah he brings you in um
and i i pretended which i often do with
like big people when i when like big
exuberant people when i hug when i get
like bear hugged i pretend to be like
hurt and i go i was like so he hugs me
and i was like ah
oh my god oh
and uh i
it was too it was too convincing a
performance because he was like he got a
little he got nervous he was like oh my
god are you okay oh my god yeah then it
got awkward was he hugging
harder than normal no
no it was just like he was just bigger
than me and he enveloped me and
i just thought i was so excited to see
him i was probably squeezing him harder
than he was squeezing me
uh you know donald faison is a really
good hugger
some i
i'd like a good hug
it's nice to be hugging but it doesn't
like a good hug by a big guy what does
that say does that mean said uh you're
craving for physical intimacy
oh maybe not necessarily sexual intimacy
but physical touch i think everyone
needs a good hug um yeah it's human
touch do you think it's a very important
thing is that like an infantilization is
that am i i think everything is in
infantilization on some level but i i
think
adults regardless of what it represents
from their childhood i think all people
need physical contact
don't you think yeah oh yeah don't you
always feel better when you have some
sort of physical contact
yeah i'm not talking about that
i know but you looked at me in a
suggestive way
i mean it depends on what the physical
touch is obviously
certain physical you don't want like a
much sweaty handshake from a stranger
yeah that's not a good physical thought
sure that's true
yeah uh he does seem like someone would
be fun to touch though he is
he's a good hugger yeah
um
his voice sounds like
he was at a like a justin bieber concert
and was screaming during the entire
thing that's what do you think justin
bieber well isn't that the funniest
thing to picture yeah yeah that him like
in a sea of like destiny's child
that was funnier justin bieber just to
see him around
those twin girls i bet guys like him who
do i'm sure there are guys who legit
legitimately like justin bieber or let's
say that like k-pop band or some band
that is popular among mostly teenage
girls and they can't
go it must be frustrating for them
because
they might be you know seen as being
like perverted yeah
uh must be sad for this guy that
population of the bieber fans
but how many people do you think that
represents probably not many but like
i'm for the seven or eight of them out
there it's like well i can't i'd love to
go to the show you'd have to go in some
sort of disguise i guess what disguise
to just how could you disguise your
adultness well not your adultness but
your
your specific adult that's who you are
yeah but i don't have to wear a gl you
know but then you'd look more like a
pervert
yeah but as long as you were an
anonymous pervert i think
you could do it comfortably oh that's
true jeff garland is famous so if he's
exactly like no
uh-huh that's true
or or would perverts not even go to our
business anonymous pervert is a good
name for something should be his next
special
[Laughter]
that's funny and isn't it speaking of a
special uh
it's so interesting how that how he he
alludes to that incident that we talked
about that he wouldn't talk about with
the car and the one who took a spot how
that set into motion all these like
really drastic things in his life yeah
i didn't know that he kind of maybe he
mentions it in the special i think but
it didn't really dawn on me that like
that resulted in his
wife leaving it's a pretty crazy thing i
you know i was thinking about this last
just and i were watching an episode of
entourage last night
i know why did i say it like that
entourage
uh entourage
and i guess you have to french word i
know but you have to over elite
friendship entourage with adrien grenier
we were watching the episode where ari
uh gerald ferrara ari's wife leaves them
because he um
gets into this
profanity-ridden tirade uh in public in
front of her oh good god what a great
scene and she and that's like the straw
that breaks the camel's back and she
leaves them and she's so humiliated
spoiler alert uh it reminded me of
jeff garland though and how
that
incident with the woman uh in the
parking lot where he gets arrested
uh that was the thing that was the
catalyst that ended his marriage
and
i mean it kind of makes sense because
especially if things are on shaky i mean
not to analyze a relationship that i've
never experienced between but it makes
sense that if they were already on some
shaky ground that a thing like that
like a public humiliation like that
would would would be the straw that's
true in fact that's true it's really sad
and he got arrested for it i mean it was
a major thing he seems
like he's bounced back though wouldn't
you say absolutely that difficult year
he seems really uh
brilliant yeah buoyant but also like
he just seems more free now there seems
like unfettered like um he's not
burdened but by something there's some
something kind of
slightly more desperate i don't want to
say i don't know well you know he seemed
like that to me but i thought uh i
thought it was only because i knew him
in such a specific context yeah verb
where
it's like in the interview he seemed
like a slightly
more toned down version of the guy he
plays on curb i was curious about how he
would uh how he would be because i think
that performance is so
natural i do too i don't think he's
playing like a man exactly he's just
playing himself exactly um but he seems
like a calmer version of that character
yeah so
maybe that's maybe there's something to
that i don't i don't think you're wrong
i don't think you're wrong to assess him
that way
and i think that's just so close to who
he is i think right um uh i didn't know
that he
he came up with the idea
did you know that from
i knew that because i had heard him on
dax's podcast and i've forgotten that
this is pretty crazy i know
yeah i mean it's such a good idea but
obviously like that one sped do you
remember that with the first the pilot
yes it was it was them putting on a show
for yeah that's all it was it was
supposed to be a one-off
special at least that was his idea but i
guess he swooped into a executive
producer well it makes sense because he
has such an easy and he talks about this
such an easy rapport with larry david i
would imagine a lot of people around
larry
in his orbit
or certainly like auditioning for that
show would
would be a lot more
nervous yes i mean that's why
ted danson's so good on it and uh really
confident people confident people who
know him who like don't need anything
from him
you know uh
yeah that's true that's true and i guess
jeff was one of them and that's why i
think the last season of curb it it
started to feel a little like a little
different because do you remember that
they started having guest stars on who
yes who would try to be funny trying
like two
yeah well i'm sure great accomplished
improv people yeah but you could tell
the difference between someone who's oh
my god just naturally knows him and he's
kind of living in the scene naturally
versus someone who is coming in with a
loaded gun trying to be honest and i
can't imagine the pressure that's why i
think like younger actors who who are
able to just kind of be natural and not
go for the jokes in on that show are so
impressive to me like
jillian bell was really great on and rob
huebel and
you know where they're just kind of
playing the intentions and not not
looking for the laugh but i think fear
is a key thing because that's why
that's what's stuck out uh to me about
him in this interview is that he he
imagine he mentions a few times that he
is funny for one thing but he says it
not in a braggy way he says it like just
as a matter of fact you're like oh when
i was eight years old i knew i wanted to
be a comedian because i was always the
funniest kid in class and i was you know
i made everyone laugh yeah there's no
false modesty exactly but there's
there's no fear
and i think in order to
be really good on a show like that great
on a show like that
you need to be fearless and in his
special i noticed that
a lot of what's funny about the special
is him just interacting with the
audience and and chit-chatting with
people in the crowd and there's a real
ease and fearlessness to him that he's
not there's nothing performative about
him yeah i think that's why that's why
he works so well on that show that is
true he is not at all trying to be funny
yeah and it's not you don't get the
sense that like oh he's going to be
upset if this joke doesn't work right
he's just kind of like is relaxed yeah
there's something very relaxed about him
um that's why it was weird speaking of
entourage to see him when when we were
watching entire entourage
he popped up on it he's in an episode of
like i think season six or seven
uh and i know him so well on curb
and i know entourage was hbo we just
sort of figured he's and there are a lot
of people playing themselves on
entourage um
but he was playing
a writer
uh a gay screenwriter yeah and it was so
strange i mean he was good on it very
natural strangely he wasn't playing
himself though but it was strange it was
a small part and it was a part that he
did like
well into the kirby enthusiasm run it
was really through me it was yeah it's
really strange but he's kind of always
himself and he admits that he's like i'm
just yeah i'm as good as the material
i'm given and i i don't he's not going
to elevate a shitty script you know he's
he was saying that some actors
are able to do that they're able to take
something that's
you know more mediocre and
rise above itself yeah but he's like i
can't do that he's like i'm only as good
as what's given to me
that ed norton can do that i don't think
he's giving himself enough credit for
his acting skills he uh he was talking
about his
his how he lost all that weight
and he was
and it was an interesting way of of
putting it where he said that he doesn't
see
first of all it's i think it's
remarkable that he was able to do this i
know when he had he was talking about
eating like an entire fudge of the whale
cakes and eating like 30 donuts at a
time it's amazing that someone who does
that can can just stop yeah um that must
have been a really miserable couple
weeks but
he was saying that he doesn't
see something like ice cream now as a
treat
yes because then he it operates the
floodgates yeah because then that makes
that that sort of shines the life of how
he puts it but that kind of shines light
on the fact that he's an addict yeah and
it's like this thing that he
craves i know it's it's something i
never really
the psychology of that is interesting
it's like
i'm not gonna give it
that kind of power respect almost power
and and another interesting thing he was
talking about you see it as a as
something bad as like right
right for your body right and it make
that that fact makes it more appealing
in a way because it's like you know you
can't have it that's true and it makes
you crave it more probably
psychologically oh that's so interesting
i once thought that of cigarettes uh oh
like it'd be a treat to have a cigarette
after but then you have it and then
you're like
what would i do you
um but he was saying that the idea of
sitting in your feelings yeah and just
experiencing your feelings
instead of
eating like eating away the feelings
yeah that's what he had to learn to do
so whether it's a good feeling or a bad
feeling and i never thought it thought
about it this way where if you're trying
to quit something anything any vice
um the reason that vice exists is
because you're using that vice to cover
up some feeling trolls to try to numb
yourself on some level and he was doing
it with food and he said he had to learn
to
kind of sit and exist with his feelings
i think
it's interesting now i think people do
that all the time with their phones with
their with technology that oh my god
it's so rare now to just sit and feel
things i know it's because now we have a
million options a million ways of i
found myself covering it uh if i have a
moment of like boredom or
it may be related to even a moment of
depression or melancholy i go to my
phone right
i go you want that little serotonin bump
yeah christian and i did a
satire a satirical piece
that you can see on our website the
other cabin.com uh called the real
stephen blatt and it was about a kid who
becomes obsessed with his phone and now
art imitating life
i found myself like
ever since i got this [ __ ] instagram
i would in a moment of
peace i could just be sitting i could be
reading i'd i could be looking out the
window and
looking at a you know i know everyone go
follow justin on instagram it's
justin long
i
i'm cutting back so uh
um you really put your foot in your
mouth when you uh ask
how his parents are oh my god and how
they're both dead
i know
um i know but he doesn't uh no he he
doesn't hold it against me does he just
hold it against you yeah that's good
in fact he he goes out of his way to not
make me to make me feel comfortable
about my gaff
social gap
it's i thought it was so funny that his
mom
uh hates three things hated oh yeah
oh yeah uh bananas frankenstein's
monster and johnny cash yes and i
thought if you polled the entire world
uh how many ask them that question what
are the three things you hate the most
with the world buddy i don't think there
would be anybody else who hated those
three things they're so random so random
bananas yeah i get each of them
individually too i also get frankenstein
and johnny cash like they have similar
vibes potent you could argue together no
no like
a person hating both those things i
think i get that too i i don't but i
can't know hey johnny
what's your order of like
favorite to least favorite of those
three yeah huh
um you could have okay eliminate them in
your life okay i would do
can i guess what yours is yeah i would i
would say
the best to worst yeah uh
bananas johnny cash frankenstein you're
right yeah you don't both have to think
wow well and bananas not because i love
bananas but because bananas are useful
they're so useful and i love things like
banana bread
um and banana
you know is a good thing in smoothies
and stuff
and i love johnny cash's music i do
do without it i know frankenstein's
monster is a cool character but i i've
seen it you know i get it i don't need
to see it again
yeah i mean he just kind of lumbers
around he doesn't do that much great
[ __ ] but you know would be tough to give
up johnny cash maybe i didn't consider
this uh in a karaoke context because
because you do i often go to johnny cash
i'd still have neil's lazy karaoke no
because my voice has gotten deeper over
the years and i know but it's there's
not much of a performance
but with karaoke you're supposed to do
something
lively and well i can make it lively oh
don't worry
you think too much about about your
vocal quality and i hear the training
coming yeah terrible it's rolling around
the bend i finally he really clearly
wanted to elevate your relationship from
acquaintance to friend and i really
think you should i want to in fact i
reached out to him on instagram when i
was wasting time it went down in the dms
yeah i dm'd him
uh
who sings that song it goes down and
then where did we hear that song i don't
remember
i don't hear it anymore
uh but
he yeah he hasn't written back yet
but i have his number too i got it like
i told that scintillating story at the
top of this outro at the intro of this
outfit that was a killer uh do you want
to read a letter yes you know i also
thought that grandma do you know grandma
sent us that letter
from one of our relatives about her
episode last week by the way thank you
for all the positive feedback she's so
like tickled and thrilled that people
and as are we she's more sick than women
tickled is sickled in understatement
she's very excited by it yeah she's like
the toast of her
condom
complex yeah but it's it's been such
great feedback and thank you guys for
you know we can't answer them all but
i've heard some really nice ones on
instagram too where it's brought up
memories of other people's grandparents
and um
and i hope it inspires people to
ask more questions and and try to learn
about their crime but we're so happy we
did just selfishly it also made me wish
that we had more
centenarian relatives
because yeah people really seem to
respond to that wait is it centenarian
or centurion
centurion's a guard centenary i think
centenary oh you know i miss i i
incorrectly wrote that on instagram oh
really i think it's i could be wrong uh
i thought it was centenarian i think
you're right um but yeah thank you that
was she was she is so flattered that
people have responded i sent her a bunch
of
letters oh reviews and yeah she seems to
really love them well she sent us a
letter speaking of letters we're about
to read one now but she sent us one from
a relative of ours who
really appreciated
learned things about her that she didn't
know and learned things about her own
mother
who who uh passed away that she didn't
know um anyway then maybe we'll have uh
grandma on again at some point yes or
maybe she'll get her own podcast uh and
put us out of business hey yeah she's
she was so good so let's read this
letter this is from leslie l
uh subject well grandma jody just
happened
dear brothers long both of you were
wondering so intently if your listeners
would find the grandma jody episode
interesting she is your grandma but not
our grandma right fret not not only was
she interesting she was fascinating and
incredibly inspiring ah
i was decorating my house for
thanksgiving while listening and her
laughter enthusiasm for life and
incredibly positive attitude put me in a
festive holiday mood man she's the
embodiment of what really matters in
life loving family sharing stories and
practicing gratitude what an incredible
woman your grandmother is i feel bad
reading this so fast but i just want to
you guys are really lucky and i know you
won't mind how heavy that casket may end
up being lol oh my god
that's funny two days ago i attended a
beautiful yet emotionally gut-wrenching
memorial for my dear friend who passed
from cancer she was only 62. god
i've been in a bit of a funk since then
hearing grandma jody speak so
beautifully and succinctly at the age of
102 reminded me that not all the good
die young and that longevity can prevail
and kudos to your other granny too this
episode has inspired me to ask my
elderly parents and family members to
share more stories and memories with me
you know why because life is sometimes
short and other times it may be quite
long we just have no way of knowing
either way the family stories need to be
told heard and shared thanks for this
awesome episode keep up the great work
what you're doing with your podcast is
simply divine
that's fine happy thanksgiving to you
and yours fondly leslie i'm leslie with
no e at the end god is that nice
so this year and that is um
echoes a lot of like we said a lot of
the sentiments that we have been hearing
and and uh we're so grateful and
our grandmother is grateful that um she
has inspired people in any way
even if it's to just invest in
some of the older people in your life a
little bit more and discover a little
bit more about them um and i'm so sorry
that your friend passed uh
and that's i wanna it's too we don't
have enough time to i wish i could ask
you about why you don't have an e at the
end of your name
leslie the burning question yeah um but
but thanks for thanks leslie and thanks
for everyone for writing uh like justin
said we've we've gotten so many
letters and uh reading them all and uh
we wish we could read them all out loud
to you guys but um the show is not long
enough
but and if you want to write in yes uh
our email is life is short at
wondery.com
and uh
that's it
yeah that's the show that's our show
thanks jeff garland thanks jeff garland
and all the shorties out there and
please convince larry to not only never
stop making kirby enthusiasm but no if
he wants to come on that'd be cool too
yeah we're not asking you to ask him
because i know but if you're like if it
comes out if it comes up organically in
conversation and you know there's a
slight chance that larry david's
listening slight
okay but i'll take it life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
so this has been life is short i'm your
host justin long our producer of life is
short i forget how to do this oh my god
it's produced by christian long and
megan monaco our senior producer is
michelle
nicknamed me sorry our audio engineer
here is
marcelino via pondo executive producers
are marcia louis and hernan lopez for
wondering see you next week
[Music]
do birds get fat are there fat birds
penguins
might have fat i don't know can can uh
like pigeons get fat
i think i've seen a fat pigeon like if
pigeons
found um like a tub of like of kfc
exactly
if they yeah you know because pigeons
can just kind of eat what they can
yeah then it's usually like that's true
scraps like crabs but if somehow they're
like like a ten piece bowl oh my god
yeah or or
like a swimming pool full of
food for them that they just had access
to would they keep eating until
i mean not until they die but
until when yeah how much do you don't
know those things eat
what animal eats until they got cats
right don't catch uh do you think i
think i think cats don't know when to
stop eating oh really yeah maybe
maybe because on the like serengeti like
wild cats are
they have to they don't know when their
next meals so they have to like eat a
ton
don't cats do that don't they eat like a
massive amount like anacondas they eat
whatever's in front of them like they
don't they don't eat they don't stop
when they're full right right huh
but there must be an evolutionary reason
for that
you